[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
heute gibt es geniale Fladenbrote die
könnt ihr beim Grillen als Beilage dazu
nehmen oder zum Beispiel auch füllen wie
ein Döner oder ein Panini
[Musik]
alles was ihr dafür tun müsst ist einen
Hefeteig herzustellen und zu kneten und
am besten macht ihr den mit einem
Vorteig das heißt wenn ihr wisst dass
ihr morgen Fladenbrot haben wollt setzt
ihr am besten heute schon einen Vortrag
an den Vorteil Kritik zusammen und aus
250 g Mehl 250 g Wasser und ein Gramm
Hefe das ist der Vorteil dass man da
wirklich nur ganz wenig Hefe braucht und
eben nicht zu diesen Hefe Geschmack habt
ihr könnt aber auch sagen okay ich nehme
jetzt einfach den Hefe Geschmack in Kauf
sowie bei herkömmlichen Hefegebäck so
wie wir Baguette Magie immer machen das
magische Baguette oder andere Brote und
dann habt ihr nicht diese lange Zeit
aber ich leg's euch ans Herz Wasser Hefe
und Mehl verrühren und einfach in einer
Schüssel über Nacht darunter stehen
lassen am Ende sieht das ganze dann
nämlich so aus das ist der Vorteil und
man sieht hier wirklich auch ganz gut
dass er ganz toll aufgegangen ist das
ganze schon Gehren konnte und diesen
Vorteig verwende ich jetzt und den
haupthefe der herzustellen also nehmen
sie den Vorteig fünf Gramm Hefe 50g
Wasser
50 Gramm Mehl einen Teelöffel Salz einen
Esslöffel Joghurt und einen Esslöffel
Olivenöl und falls ihr sagt ihr wollt es
nicht einen Tag vorher ansetzen dann
einfach alle Zutaten nehmen also Wasser
und das Mehl hier mit dazu und etwas
mehr Hefe verwenden ganz einfach und
dann länger aufgehen lassen aber im
Geschmack in der Konsistenz ist ändert
sich natürlich und so eine längere
Gehzeit ist halt schon förderlich weil
es einfach besser schmeckt der
körperlicher ist und das Gebäck besser
und luftig aufgeht
[Musik]
und dann für 10 Minuten kneten lassen
jetzt sieht der Teig perfekt aus ich
nehme jetzt hier raus Fette die Hände
ein bisschen mit Öl und mach mal richtig
schöne Kugel aus und dann darf der Teig
nämlich abgedeckt eine Stunde aufgehen
oder auch gerne eine halbe Stunde bei
der Stufe im Backofen falls ihr einen
Backofen habt ansonsten wie gesagt
einfach eine Stunde
da dürft ihr euch nicht wundern der Teig
ist echt ein bisschen klebriger als
sonst aber er ist super elastisch
der Teig ist jetzt wunderbar aufgegangen
und daraus forme ich jetzt vier Fladen
könnt ihr natürlich auch kleiner
zubereiten dann habt ihr so kleine
minifaden das ist auch ganz süß
[Musik]
Formen einfach von außen nach innen
ziehen damit sich hier eine schöne
glatte Fläche bildet und wenn ihr
braucht ein bisschen die Hände bemehlen
dann umdrehen
und rundformen
weil die Fladenbrote jetzt noch sehr gut
aufgehen werden habe ich jetzt hier mal
nur zwei auf einem Blech ihr könnt
natürlich auch vier auf einem Blech
setzen das kann da nur passieren dass
der aneinander kleben ihr deckt die
jetzt ab mit einem sauberen Geschirrtuch
oder packt sie einfach in den Backofen
bei gerstufe für eine Stunde bis sie
eben sich verdoppelt haben bei der Stufe
nur eine halbe Stunde und dann werden
sie anschließend mit einer Mischung aus
Eigelb und Joghurt bestrichen mit Sesam
und Schwarzkümmel bestreut und gebacken
[Musik]
und jetzt kommen die Fladenbrote in den
Backofen bei 190 Grad Heißluft da kann
ich nämlich beide parallel backen und
nach dem Backen ist ganz wichtig dass
ihr sie direkt einschlagt mit einem
sauberen Küchentuch damit es so ein
bisschen ausdampfen können und schön
weich werden ich bin so gespannt
[Musik]
ich habe die Brote bei der vierte
Heißluft gebacken mit Dampfstoß zwei und
jetzt guckt sie euch ja
sind die schön
die sind so schön und die packe ich
jetzt schnell in ein sauberes
Geschirrtuch damit sie ausdampfen kann
die besten Fladenbrote werden die ihr
jemals gemacht habt
[Musik]
die könnt ihr vorbereiten nach dem
Abkühlen auch einfrieren immer wieder
aufbacken am nächsten Tag im Toaster
oder auf dem
wie heißt das den Kontaktgrill
Kontaktgrill einfach noch mal zubereiten
ihr könnt sie füllen ihr könnt sie so
pur essen macht wirklich damit was ihr
wollt die Brote sind der Oberhammer das
Rezept findet ihr in meiner App und auf
meinem Blog ich wünsche euch viel Spaß
dabei und falls ihr noch Rezept Wünsche
habt dann schreibt sie mir wie immer
[Musik]